henceforth
the men and women of the united states
space force
will be known as guardians
oh no
no it can't be
[Applause]
from our president a man who is actually
in space
right now space farce
space
[Music]
space is a war fighting domain
when it comes to the outer reaches of
space you are that strength
if you rise on the wings of the dawn if
you settle on the far
side of the sea even if you go up
to the heavens what the hell that there
his hand will guide you and his right
hand will hold you fast
to defend america and defend our freedom
from space
[Music]
yesterday we had three big ones really
big
suppression balls you don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you say
to your wife or you say to your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leading
soaking wet already suppression balls
red wave i'm
soaking
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for joe biden we are about
to hear
uh some important announcements related
to the coronavirus pandemic
and hopefully we continue to see numbers
go in the right direction we've been
tracking all of this very very closely
as you can see the average of cases
peaked
right around january 12th and it has
been declining since
and it looks to be leveling off a little
bit so we've got to keep vaccinating
keep vaccinating keep vaccinating
and moving on down we are now
at the point where the united states has
given out
23 and a half million shots
and is up to one and a quarter million
doses per day remember joe biden's goal
was a million a day
we are surpassing that we're at 1.25
yesterday joe biden said let's see if we
can get to 1.5 million
uh doses uh a day and that would of
course
be very very good so we're going to hear
from joe biden in a little bit and i'm
looking forward to seeing
uh what ideas he has and what we are
expecting to see going forward i think
it would be a fantastic thing
will i open phone lines today i haven't
opened phone lines for a while
yeah i will i mean we've got a goal of a
hundred website members and twitch subs
i think it's a realistic goal yesterday
i didn't even mention it and we got 35
so i will say phone lines will open if
and when we get to 100. um
sam cedar mentioned your discounts on
his on his show today
if that's true please get me a clip i
would love to review that
uh i was texting with sam today actually
um
if that you know sometimes people try to
troll me i'm like okay
you got me i fell for it but um if
sam did that that would be a funny clip
to play on the show so let's take a look
at that
and um also want to say thanks to
kimiolo
bic or no black bear
oh kimiolo and blackbear for uh signing
up with
twitch subscriptions i very much
appreciate that
uh diana vaccarelli says thoughts on
executive order ending contracts with
private prisons didn't get a chance to
do much research i have not looked at
that yet either
myself myself diana um
would like to take a look at that and i
will
i certainly certainly will believe you
me
um i do have memes
okay so let me tell you what i have
today i'll give you the full list of
what i have today
and and then we'll look at the order in
which we we will look at things
um i have a voicemail
from a caller who is sick of troy york
there's been controversy in the audience
should i play troy york voicemails or
should i not
i have a caller who is absolutely shot
out of a cannon
completely shot out of a cannon um
saying
a lot of horrible things about troy york
i have a video of
the union worker who joe biden snapped
at
being interviewed by newsmax exclusive
newsmax interviewed that guy and it may
be even more newsworthy
than when sean hannity interviewed the
blind computer repairman
i also have even more clips today of
steve
peter ducey asking really dumb questions
of both joe biden and jen
sackey so there's a lot of stuff
i don't know where you guys want me to
start sean says what are your top five
tips for being a beta male
uh i'd have to think about that
i'd have to think about that i don't i
don't know offhand but that's certainly
something i would be uh
i i would be willing to think about uh
okay
wow yeah people oh and i have a new meme
i haven't
let's just do the new meme first the the
new meme is pretty funny
this was sent to me by eaton by vultures
that's a reddit username this is the
david livestream starter pack so as you
can see
we've got the counter which at this
point was 26
out of 100 me quoting what chakaseki has
said via super chat
although today chakaseki hasn't said
anything via super chat
mentioning discord i don't know if this
is use of or
mention of the ban hammer stream is
starting soon but the stream doesn't
actually start soon
an incredible number of people watching
this says 251 thousand we've never had
that many the most we've ever had is 120
000 people watching
um a variety of super chats me looking
really confused
off screen at what i am seeing that's
common
me saying okay at some point david is
unsure
why there is no audio or is unclear
where audio is coming from that's like
every stream that's absolutely accurate
me saying wow the title says something
is breaking
and mentions of twitch this is a nice
meme it's wholesome
it's accurate the thing about a good
meme
is it has to be ten percent exaggerated
if you exaggerated a thousand percent
it no longer resembles the reality of
the show if you don't exaggerate at all
it's not really a joke so if you
exaggerate
by 10 or 15 percent the absurdity of
what happens on these live streams
you uh you do a really really good job
okay so that's that that's the meme i
had
for everybody so we've got that um
under control um
thank you to kai dizzle for gifting five
subs sally annette as well as chaotic
stasis
gatsby cat conkey matrix japid
all of whom are signing up via twitch um
and that is that's a plus 10 as i see it
putting us at 12.
okay radical liberal raphael warnock
says love the show thanks david
abrasive adam i looked back at the news
this day in trump's presidency and yep
in 2017 he was complaining about dead
people voting and people voting twice
right win or lose those are trump's
complaints
can't wait for you on the hang up
tomorrow with matt i don't know what
that even means
ryan can't wait for you on the hang up
tomorrow with matt
what do i have on my schedule
oh i'm on matt dillahunty's show
tomorrow night
thanks ryan i would have noticed it when
i reviewed my schedule tomorrow morning
but yes tomorrow night at eight i guess
it's eight eastern i will be on with
matt dillahunty
a friend of the show which is cool
appreciate the reminder
dan says do you think the magnitude of
the logistics of the vaccine in the u.s
was manageable if looking back to say
march
april i don't know what you mean by that
because we didn't have any vaccine to
distribute back
back then so i'm not i'm not sure i know
what you mean dan i really appreciate
the super chat
but i don't i don't exactly know what
you mean
um here is a
oh people are saying the coupon code is
not working oh come on guys
that that that can't be the case
whenever i'm told the coupon that should
be part of the meme viewer says coupon
code isn't working
let's see here okay sign up
coupon code better21 i click
off there it is
guys the coupon code is working the
coupon code is working
if you're using a really aggressive vpn
maybe that routes through russia you
it's possible that some elements on the
website won't work but the coupon code
is working okay guys the coupon code is
better21 and it's working
beautiful oh i got tricked okay jeez
big win big win um
okay let me get to this voicemail
so this is there's been a lot of
controversy among the audience as to
whether i should play
troy york voicemails i'm warning you
guys
there is aggressive language here this
is someone who is
furious with troy york take a listen to
this
yeah first uh i've had a few but
i started watching okay fair drunk
caller is furious with troy york
today i'm tony you know from chicago
troy or you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a
closeted homosexual i'm heterosexual
i love homosexuals i wish i was
homosexual
i've not picked up on the fact that troy
york's anger with me
is because he's in love with me i've not
i've not picked up on that
i used to be an alpha male i'm i'm
hoping to be more
more of a beta male today but you're a
closeted i think you have a crush
be honest with yourself you know what
there is something interesting
i have picked up on the fact that troy
york does seem to really be
sort of smitten not in a romantic way
but just sort of smitten with with
youtube personalities i've gotten that
impression but i don't think that he's
in love with me
crush on as david everything else
i i think uh biden's uh thing tonight
it was really kind of more it was very
intellectual
so i had to pause it many times go back
and like
there's a lot of kind of it was kind of
you know you for people saying this guy
sounds drunk he's admitting to be drunk
really hard to pay attention to every
word kind of because there are a lot of
words there's a few words i had to
google uh that's okay and
but um so that was kind of i was
wondering
why you know like you know he could just
kind of be a little more
this is a great caller by the way or uh
easily understood to the common person i
think
because i'm a little smarter than you i
would spare when i was old
if you're watching my show and you like
it you're probably rather than like
you know how 100 iq is average i think
that you basically it's like 103
if you enjoy this show it's a small it's
a small upgrade to iq
it was a little difficult and then the
question started and
um yeah i mean i think he did good and i
love everything he's doing so far i mean
like god bless his heart right i'm i'm
i was a born catholic but i'm actually
more of an atheist nowadays but that's
okay but no i
bless his heart you know um he said they
got a lot of impact uh come up tomorrow
uh they have a lot of them in that place
pamela
but i didn't understand why he couldn't
answer the question about the 51
the uh reconciliation or whatever they
call it
well i can't answer that okay anyway so
we're off the troy york part but that is
a brutal
shot across the bow uh against against
troy york
thanks to jonathan harmon for signing up
at joinpackman.com
and also a big thank you to denny dixon
denny dixon has signed up at
joinedpakman.com putting us at 14.
also on twitch a lot is happening
including some gifted subs from
astrolycos
so as far as twitch goes we're plus 7
and that puts us at
21. a few other super chats christian
ventura says david love the show do you
prefer to say argentinian versus
argentine
which is the actual appropriate u.s
demon demonim for anything
related to argentina my understanding i
grew up saying argentinian
i was told argentine is more british
whereas argentinian is more american
that could be complete bs
i say argentinian amy d likes the david
pakman wack pack
says did you see that president biden is
to order doj to end private prison
contracts
it was mentioned earlier i've not read
about it so i will read about it
and ferret queen says happy early
birthday can you tell the groundhog to
make this cold weather go away sincerely
jen from the rhode island massachusetts
border
yes thank you for the early birthday
still a ways away
how concerned am i about covet variants
and potential for future variants well
i'm going i'm trying not to get uh go
beyond what the science is telling us
what the science is telling us is that
the virus is mutating
roughly at the speed which we would
expect based on the type of virus
it appears as though the vaccines are as
effective against the uk virus less
effective against the south africa
the uk variant less effective against
the south african variant
but apparently not so much less
effective that it will prevent
immunity and the brazilian variant is a
question mark right now moderna working
on what they're calling an insurance
policy modified
third booster which would be months away
for sure
but um i think that everybody is
handling everything
the way that it can best be handled at
this point in time okay
i think we've just got to keep the more
we vaccinate
the fewer people that will get the
the virus and it will slow down the
mutation
so that's that's the gist of it david
can you please call that caller back
i'm a gay teen and the comment he made
about
people being closeted hurt well p some
people are some people are closeted
that's that's true
saw right wing newspapers today raving
about the chaos of vaccines and blaming
biden fully
yeah i know it's they're predictable
they're predictable uh we are in the
middle of a level five hype train on
twitch with two full minutes to go
um the best we've ever done is in the
600 percent i believe
i don't think we've ever gone beyond
600-ish percent
um let's go now to
[Music]
oh um check this out so i did a clip
it's already on my youtube
channel of steve peter ducey over the
last few days
asking some really dumb questions during
press briefings
he asked a bunch this is all just from
today okay guys let's listen to a couple
of these i think you'll enjoy this
another question uh the president says
that he hopes
that the senate leadership can continue
uh can do an impeachment trial while
working on the people's business
what if they can't okay hypothetical and
again
joe biden should have nothing to do with
what is going on in the senate
period joe biden is not going to
influence impeachment one way or the
other that's it
these hypotheticals are really silly
here's another doozy from ducey
just one more the riots in portland and
the violence in portland recently
there was some discussion earlier about
the january 6th rioters being reviewed
by the dni
as domestic violent extremists are the
rioters in portland also being
viewed through the same lens or is that
something different that's the white
house
i think we you and i talked about this
yesterday and conveyed that
uh all violence happening around the
country will be reviewed
see this is i like that gen saki if gen
saki starts arguing and says
you know what's happening in portland is
different from dc
it's much smaller and also the dc stuff
wasn't cited by trump whereas the
portland stuff was not
just say we're going to review
everything that's exactly the way to
handle it we'll review everything and
we'll make a determination period
um okay other things going on here
is here is steve peter ducey again there
is a report now that
the chief financial officer of florida
has sent a letter to the international
olympic committee that florida would
like to host the olympics if japan next
year
is uncomfortable because of the pandemic
is a florida olympics
in 2021 something you can see the white
house supporting
well that's a lot of steps that need to
take place and i don't know the entire
process of the olympics but yeah she
says go talk to the olympic committee
again it's like
it he asserts florida said something
on the basis of if japan makes a
decision they haven't yet made
and if all of that were to happen and
the olympic committee liked it
what would joe biden's position be have
you seen the coveted numbers
peter steve have you seen the peter the
the the covet numbers
uh just handling it very very well this
question was also pretty dumb
i don't even know who this guy is he was
trying to one-up steve peter
yesterday former president trump
endorsed sarah huckabee sanders for
governor of arkansas in 2022
where does president biden stand on that
particular race and how high is this on
his list of priorities
well how high is the arkansas republican
gubernatorial primary on the president's
list of powers
not high that is just the best
has joe biden taken a position on the on
the primary
among republicans in arkansas that's two
two years away uh give me a break it it
and she is handling that very very well
um
and then the last thing on this i like
that
biden seems to like messing with steve
peter
and um yesterday he went to him knowing
that he asks ridiculous questions
here is peter ducey yelling out what did
you talk to putin about
mr president about
you he sends his best
um i i love how everybody's handling now
by the way there's a syria this is
obviously disaster porn and and it's
entertaining
but there's actually a real lesson here
if this had not not if
when you saw fact-based adversarial
questions
asked of kaylee mcinanni or trump or
whatever
the reporters would sometimes get thrown
out and have their press credentials
removed like the jim acosta fiasco
they would be called nasty the person at
the lectern would denounce media
as an institution they would start
attacking and lecturing the entire room
really important lesson here in the
differences in terms of how
they were the these have been handled
and i think that that's like the serious
takeaway
um from from what we are seeing here but
i i love how jenn sackey
and um and and biden himself have been
handling
steve peter ducey so far i love it um
okay big thank you to the 15
additional people who signed up via
twitch sub i i can't go back and thank
everybody but know that i really
appreciate it i also want to say thanks
to
lakia stone
josh vinson and philip rang
for signing up at joinpakman.com just a
reminder i don't mention this often
we do have a membership program on our
website joinpakman.com it's the number
one funding source for what we do
it's the most direct way to support what
we do
and the coupon code better21
is there's nothing better than that
coupon code really so just just a
reminder
um and we will open up phone lines if if
we get to that goal of 100.
let's look at some other super chats
ducey seems like he didn't earn his job
must be the nepotism
i don't know enough about it
rebel rebel you're getting the ban
hammer for being against freedom of
press david please
ban this right-wing troll uh moderators
please review the messages of rebel
rebel rebel
unknown prodigy why am i not wearing a
teddy stratford shirt oh i'm wearing my
mustard uh sweater
david x trump supporter here began
deprogramming with impeachment
one woke me up your content big part of
me
reconnecting with reason thank you so
much glad to hear it
glad to hear it jared says 45 was a
horrific authoritarian fascist but with
him at the helm
democrats were able to take full control
of the government thinking about this in
a choose your enemies kind of way
should we root for trumpism well no
trump
trump led to republicans losing the
house senate and white house
but then if you just leave him there
then you can't ever do anything so no
the whole point is at some point you
take it take control and you try to do
some things that's that's the whole gist
of it
david did you lola yolo gme stocks
what are what are gme stocks can anybody
tell me
i'm not familiar with that what does gme
stand for
gamestop oh what happened with game
stock
i'm not even sure people what's going on
let's see
game stop gme
gamestop what it doubled today what is
going what what did gamestop do
i don't even know what what could
possibly explain this
went from 20 to 140. yeah i have no idea
um i tend to basically uh invest for the
long term and i own only a few
stocks i've been clear about the stocks
i've owned for for years and years and
years
um tesla of course since 2015
amazon and google since around 2014
um serious radio i bought live i've said
all this stuff before i bought live
nation
around mid-march when it crashed due to
the virus
um zoom
uh what else i don't remember what
stocks
bayer i bought at one point um
but anyway yeah i only have like three
what percent would i say maybe three
percent
three four percent of my money in
individual stocks i don't even pretend
to uh i know listen my full-time thing
is hosting this show
and half of money managers can't beat
the market averages so why
why would i think i can right this is
the school of thought of warren buffett
benjamin graham jack bogle
okay uh oh people are tuning out because
i'm talking about
finance let's get out let's get out all
right let's continue here gamestop is
market speculation don't fall for it i i
won't
you and kyle kalinsky are my favorite
commentators to watch by far thank you
thought on the 15 day injunction in
texas for the 100-day delay on
deportation
don't know about it yet don't know about
it yet love the show david but don't be
uncritical of the new press secretary
just because she's biden's no i've
actually i got some
messages last week from a few people who
said i was too critical of jen
saki because i said she didn't fully
answer a question
come on guys it's going to be a long
four years if that's the standard
um oh okay yeah let's do this
this is the union worker that biden i
guess snapped at months ago he spoke out
on newsmax
right now the numbers of jobs
are thousands of jobs there's michael's
there's precision pipeline
um that would have reflected that the
pipeline was going to be constructed
um the actions that were happening
recently we were doing station work
there's hundreds of guys that got laid
off
especially during a pandemic you can
obviously feel his pain
our next guest had his own running with
biden he joins us now
detroit auto worker jerry wayne jerry uh
thanks this is a big exclusive guys okay
so much for coming back on the show um i
want to before you and i get to chatting
about what's happening here
with keystone and union jobs i want to
remind everyone
what your run-in was like with president
biden here's that
i did not say that that's not true i did
not say
but nevertheless that was your run in
with jerry you may remember when that
went
viral uh then on the campaign trail
viral okay
uh and one of the things that i i
remember you tweeting out is saying that
i looked
i believe you said i look this man of
the eye there's nothing that
he want he does not want to unite us i'm
paraphrasing but what did you mean by
that
yeah so i looked his name in his eyes
and there's a lot of emptiness behind
there not to mention that i had an
articular question that i had asked him
and he nothing uh nothing more
sophisticated than referring to yourself
as articulate
i had a very articulate question you
typically you want to leave that for
other people this this
in these 10 seconds i'm already
identifying
some trumpian here where trump talks
about how smart he is you know usually
let other people tell you how smart you
are he's determined he he has determined
that he's articulate
he wanted to be very argumentative if
this man wanted to unite he'd be able to
see that opportunity to actually have
to have a conversation with a peer and
actually come to an agreement or at
least a simple understanding he also has
determined that he's joe biden's peer
like who is he to determine that he's
joe biden's peer
that two gentlemen can actually come
across this man who and
and he's a gentleman like he's in the
first
understand there's a degree of
narcissism in the first 30 seconds
he decried himself a gentleman
articulate
and a peer of joe biden who who talks
like that
man is actually trying to take away our
constitutional rights and he's obviously
taking away our right to actually
provide for our families right now you
know he had no he how has he done that
everything's been running very smoothly
as far as
economically speaking when it comes to
the oil reserve and
what what they're doing now is
manipulating the system for a
good green new deal what is he talking
about biden doesn't even support the
green new deal he thankfully
incorporated some aspects of the green
new deal
and it's it's what is he what is this
guy talking about
the green nothing's been proposed and
biden doesn't support the green new deal
and by doing that is that you're
manipulating the people that are
actually trying to actually stand up and
innovate
just look at nancy pelosi she just
bought a whole bunch of uh options for
a stock called tesla which is the
leading innovator
with electrical vehicles so wait what
what does nancy buying tesla have to do
with anything
this is so stupid i don't see how you're
going to do two
things at the same time you're going to
go ahead and get rid of the union
workers
and then go ahead and buy into these
other companies oh wait this guy is pro
union
what they're actually going to put take
the oil industry out of business so
it seems like there's some underlying
issues there there's definitely
underlying issues here
you do see president biden notably on
the campaign see
if newsmax were real they would check
they would say
hold on a second wait wait a second
nancy supports green energy and she
bought tesla stock which is an electric
car
company what's the what's the
the inconsistency there i mean he's been
in office for almost
50. uh wait a second biden didn't run on
the green new deal what do you mean that
biden is destroying the constitution
with the green new deal he hasn't he
doesn't even support it
years now so he's very familiar with
campaigning knowing
okay afternoon all right let's go to joe
biden jeff science who's
heading up our whole cova team and uh
today what i'd like to do is to upgrade
update you on where we are
tomorrow uh we're going to begin white
house press briefings
corona virus it'll occur on a regular
basis
with mr zions and his team so we're
bringing back the pros to
talk about covet and understand any
questions you have
uh that's how we'll handle them because
we're letting science speak again
and so uh i uh i'd like to update you on
the aggressive steps we're taking to
meet
our goal of administering 100 million
cover 19 vaccine
shots within within 100 days
and to ramp up vamp the vaccine supply
as fast as we can
this will be one of the most difficult
operational challenges
we've ever undertaken as a nation i've
said that before but i must say it again
because we're going to do we're going to
everything we can to get it done
but a lot of things can go wrong along
the way
and so i've as i've said in the past we
want to give credit to everyone involved
in this vaccine effort
and the prior administration and the
science community and the medical
uh sphere for getting the program what
on earth i didn't do it i promise
for getting the program uh off the
ground
and uh that credit is absolutely due
but it's also no secret that we have
recently discovered in the final days of
the transition
and it wasn't until the final days we
got the kind of cooperation there was no
plan
that once we arrived a vaccine program
is in worse shape
than we anticipated or expected a lot of
you follow this and nobody is
i mean this sincerely the press is the
smartest group of people in town
you you hone this stuff down clearly
i think you found the same thing even
before i took office i announced a new
vaccine
a vaccination strategy which centers on
federal leadership and execution
for our whole country and that's why i
directed my cova team
to go to work immediately and how we
could step up the vaccination
efforts and the vaccinations i'm pleased
to announce
the first progress and that work today
and on day seven of my
uh my presidency uh first
here we go after review of the current
vaccine supply and manufacturing plants
i can announce that we will increase
overall
weekly vaccination distributions of
states tribes and territories
from 8.6 million doses to a minimum of
10 million doses
nice starting next week that's an
increase of 1.4 million doses per week
and you all know if i may note
parenthetically you all know know that
the vaccines are distributed to states
based on population
they're based on population and so the
smaller the state the less vaccine the
bigger the state the more they get
and uh so this can allow millions of
more americans to get vaccinated sooner
than previously anticipated well done a
long way to go though the second thing
we're increasing the transparency with
states cities and tribes
and local partners when it comes to the
vaccine
supply this is something we've heard
over and over again from both democrats
and republicans
state and local leaders that they need a
plan in order to what
they need to know what they have to plan
on they need to know what the order is
going to be
jeff had a meeting with the governors on
zoom
and and others and they're i think we're
getting
this coordinated in a way that uh
there's increased uh
uh cooperation and confidence but until
now we've had to guess how much vaccine
to expect uh for the next week and
that's what the governors had to do how
much am i getting next week this is
unacceptable
the uh you know the lives are at stake
here
from this week forward god willing will
ensure that states tribes and
territories
will now always have a reliable
three-week forecast
and what the supply they're going to get
so they'll know three weeks ahead of
time
in the third week this is going to help
make sure governors mayors and local
leaders
have greater certainty around supply so
they can carry out their plans to
vaccinate as many people as possible
so we will both increase the supply
in the short term by more than 15
percent
and give our states and local partners
more certainty about when
deliveries will arrive these two steps
are going to help increase
our prospects of hitting or exceeding
god willing
the ambitious goal of 100 million shots
in 100 days i think we're going to
exceed i also want to be clear
100 million shots in 100 days is not the
end point
it's just the start we're not stopping
there
the end goal is to beat covet 19
and the way we do that is to get more
people vaccinated which means
we have to be ready after we hit the
ground
we have to hit the goal of 100 million
shots in 100 days now that means
fewer than 100 million people getting
totally vaccinated means 100 shots
and it means somewhere between 60 maybe
less maybe more million people will have
the
because it requires two shots in many
cases
not always so today i'm directing cover
19 response coordinator jeff science
here
to work with the department of health
and human services to increase our total
supply
of vaccine for the american people
and we believe that we'll soon be able
to confirm
the purchase of an additional hundred
billion doses
beautiful the two fda authorized
vaccines
each of the two that's a hundred million
more doses of pfizer and 100 million
more doses
of modernity wow 200 million more doses
than the federal government had
previously secured
not in hand yet but ordered now we're
talking we expect these additional 200
million doses to be delivered
this summer okay and some of it will
come as early begin to come in
early summer but by the mid by the
mid-summer
that this vaccine will be there
beautiful and the order
and and that increases the total vaccine
order in the united states by 50 percent
from 400 million order to 600 million
this enough vaccine for the country to
fully vaccinate 300 americans
by end of the summer the beginning of
the fall
but we want to make look that's i want
to repeat
it'll be enough to fully vaccinate 300
americans
to beat this pandemic 300 million
and this is an aggregate plan that
doesn't leave anything on the table
or anything to chance as we've seen
happen in the past year
i've said before this is a wartime
effort
when i say when i say that people ask
wartime i say yeah more than 400
000 americans have already died i guess
411 or 12
have died in one year of this pandemic
more than all the people who died in all
the
americans who died in world war ii this
is a wartime undertaking it's not
hyperbole
and as such i directed the team to be
ready to exercise
all the authorities i have under the
defense production act
and expedite these vaccines
and we're using the defense production
act to launch full-scale
wartime effort to address the supply
shor sure he is using
from the previous administration we're
going to be working across the
government
with private industry to ramp our
production of vaccine
the protective equipment the syringes
the needles the gloves the swabs the
mask
everything is needed to protect test
vaccinate and take care of our people
well we've already identified suppliers
and we're working with them to move our
plan forward
the biggest problem i hope you're all
asking me and
by the end of the summer that you have
too much vaccine left over
you have too much equipment left over
right that's not my worry i hope that
becomes the problem
great problem to have somehow find
interruptions and supply or access
these aggressive steps to increase
vaccine supply come on top of the steps
we took
last week to get more people vaccinated
for free
to create more places for them to get
vaccinated and to mobilize more medical
teams to get shots in people's arms
we've directed fema the federal
emergency management agency
to stand up the first federally
supported community vaccination centers
and that work is underway we're working
to make vaccines available to thousands
of local
pharmacies beginning in early february
it's a couple weeks off and we know that
will enormously expand our reach
last week i also signed a declaration
to immediately begin reimbursing states
100
for the uses of their national guard to
help the covert relief effort
both getting people you get getting the
sites set up
and even using some other personnel to
administer some of the vaccines
and i think it's something imagine if
trump had done this with testing from
day one
imagine if trump had done this with
vaccination on december 1st
to help schools and businesses reopen
safely and protect the most vulnerable
and we formalize the health equity task
force
to ensure that equity is at the core of
everything we do
in urban and rural communities alike to
make sure those people most
significantly damaged have have access
access we have to change we have to move
in a direction
for those communities that are hard to
get to but the brutal truth is
it's going to take months before we can
get the majority of americans vaccinated
months in the next few months masks
not vaccines are the best defense
against covet 19.
wow experts say that wearing masks
from now on just until april would save
50
000 lives who otherwise will pass away
if we don't wear these masks
that's why i'm asking the american
people to mask up for the first hundred
days
i've issued executive orders requiring
mass on federal property and interstate
travel
trains and planes and buses one
congressman pointed out i could uh
i well he used a very anyway colorful
term to say
wearing a mask i told him to kiss my ear
i'm not going to wear a mask
well guess what not very american the
fact is you want to be patriotic you're
going to protect people
right and new cover 19 variants are
are are are are we are instituting new
measures to deal with these individuals
flying
in the united states from other
countries you've all hold if you can
hold a second you all
you've all heard about the strain the
the british strain the brazilian strain
the south african strain
and they are they seem to be more
transmittable more easily
so in addition to wearing masks everyone
flying to the united states from another
country
we need to test before they get on the
plane
and self quarantine when they arrive in
america
i'm going to close with this i now have
a national we now have a national
strategy to beat cover 19.
it's comprehensive it's based on science
not politics
it's based on truth not denial and
it is detailed it's going to require
congress to pass the american rescue
plan
to provide funding to administer the
vaccines to ramp up testing
to help schools and businesses reopen
and deliver immediate economic relief
to americans who are in badly needed
through no
fault of their own and our plan
will take time progress from our plan
will take time to measure
as people getting infected today don't
show up in case counts for weeks
and those who perish from those from the
disease die weeks after that exposure
you know despite the best our best
intentions
we're going to face setbacks which i
will always explain to you and
acknowledge
and let me be clear things are going to
continue to get worse before they get
better
the death toll experts tell us is likely
to top 500 000
by the end of next month this february
wow and cases will continue to mount we
didn't get
into this mess overnight it's going to
take months
for us to turn things around but let me
be equally clear
we're going to get through this we will
defeat this pandemic
and to a nation waiting for action let
me be
clearest on this point help is on the
way
we can do this if we come together
if we listen to the scientists as i said
tomorrow i say to the press the entire
team will be back in the business
of my cova team of answering all your i
will cover it
so thank you very much for your patience
keep the faith we're going to get this
done
and i'll always level with you about the
state of affairs thank you
mr president all right so there is joe
biden delivering a message about
coronavirus 19
and some very important developments on
vaccination
um and that i think is a a very very
exciting thing so listen let's do this
we didn't get to our goal of a hundred
so i'm not gonna do a full phone call
session but here's what i will do
let's go twitch exclusive as i mentioned
2021 is a very powerful year for twitch
for us
i'm gonna pinch off the youtube stream
pinch off the facebook stream
come over to twitch twitch.tv david
pakman
and i will open the phone lines there
okay very very simple it will be all
as it always is except we will just be
over on twitch if you're on twitch right
now
you don't have to go anywhere you can
just stay exactly where you are alright
so let's take it
i will see you at twitch.tv david pakman
right